[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
next
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello hello what is up
okay all right i know we're late all
right
this is probably karma from last time
from me being like yo guys we're on time
sorry
but the download is taking them off it's
in there
obviously we're all kind of stuck right
now
i might have gotten it
it's starting with the trailer um
this is as far as i've gotten so far so
let's see
let's call it
no see you see what i mean i should have
just let
the trailer play because that was as far
as i've gotten
but it's fine in time i'm confident
all of us will be able to
get into the service we're all literally
trying to get into the servers
at the same time so it's fine at least
you can see
here we're all struggling with the same
with the same problem um
so we're gonna hang out try to get into
the game
what's good brandon what's good chris
carolina white tiger scotty
what is up everyone how's it going happy
apex
legends legacy day
[Laughter]
um we're big chilling while we wait and
enjoy this
apex legends legacy menu screen
says no servers are found maybe we'll
try a couple of um
reset the game or something this is
actually like
the third time i've reset it
and that was the first time it even let
me like bring up the trailer so i was
like maybe
maybe we'll be in there but we're not
so i'll give it another few tries here
and then we'll restart it and see
you guys let me know in the chat if
anybody has been able to get in yet
um i mean if we're not able to get in
now
i know it's not going to be the like the
end-all be-all we will eventually be
able to get in
so we'll see you know we got to be
optimistic
in these times you know
um but yeah what is good
how is everyone going what are you guys
most excited about i know there's been
a lot of content released
with from the preview event which was
also super super fun
so what from the update are you guys
looking forward to the most
your apex is not downloading well
when i i'm on steam but i know it's a
little bit different for
every platform but on steam my download
kept downloading like
20 and then it gets stuck on 20 for a
while
so i like restarted it and when it
started back up it would keep going
um so if you're noticing your downloads
getting stuck or maybe it's not starting
i would definitely suggest
restarting steam if you're on steam or
restarting your platform
jj got in let's go you
are the beacon of light for us all now
because we're all trying to get
in
[Laughter]
i know jet they're making me jealous too
but in a good way because i want to play
too but i'm not mad at you guys for
getting in
just a little jealous cause i want to
play too but i'm happy for you guys
good for you looking forward to the new
weapons j
heck yes um the bow chick
is definitely gonna be interesting i'm
pretty bad
with weapons of that type um
so when i was trying it out i was
horrible with it
but i already saw some people doing some
trick shots and some crazy stuff i was
like
it's probably me and not the gun
actually it's definitely me and not the
kind so
just caught the battle pass noise
noise um you know what i'm going to
try and restart apex
and hope that will help right
you know the good ol turn it off and
turn it back on again
it works more often than it doesn't so
um whoo a case of ruse in the chat liza
everyone tuning in thank you guys so
much i'm sorry like i haven't been able
to get in yet
but it sounds like a few people in the
chat have been getting in
which is good news
oh snap brett from cape town what is up
thanks for tuning in
you made it into the firing range okay
that's definitely
much further than i have gotten so far
all right
um i feel like i'm definitely going to
butcher your name and i apologize
but safaite said how am i so cool how
are
you guys so cool you guys tuning in
while i'm stuck outside of the game like
i'm like you know
that gif let me in
but yeah oh respond to swedish thing
they're working on server problems
of course we knew it we knew they'd
they'd be aware of the situation
this is pretty like common i feel like
there was
a lot of hype when everyone's really
excited for something new come
coming out and you know everyone wants
to hop on it they know what time it's
dropping everyone's
waiting so we're all just excited if
anything this is a good sign
because that means there's a lot of
people trying to get in and play so
kit kat got into a match but as soon as
he died he got booted to the menu
[Music]
ah i hope you get back in because ah
you're in so bye hey i understand go
have fun and play enjoy
all the legacy goodness my friend
i'm definitely not offended whatsoever
while we're here rate volks sunglasses i
mean
i forget the name of the brand of that
shape
it's like aviator just like i'm probably
so wrong and i'm probably just like
thinking that name because she's a pilot
but i think they look pretty cool
and it's got that orange tin into the
ombre like gray at the top
to match the suit pretty good if you
asked me
pretty good you skipped school for this
stay in school oh snap all right guys
let me call the homies who are joining
me right now let me bring him in the
call i'm gonna be joined today
by jordan and my buddy nikail
jordan you guys all know jordan over at
gamespot always doing great content
and nikhil is my buddy last time
we played apex i had my algs teammate
casey ruse come join me
and it was super fun but now my other
teammate nikail is going to be here this
time so i'm actually really excited but
i'm going to call them because they both
got in
and i've not been able to get in so
let's call them
let's say hello so you guys don't just
have to hear me
jonko i'm stuck in origin nightmare land
i mean we're all in nightmare line
except for you guys apparently
what's up mikhail you are in please tell
us what it's like
on on the other side so
it's glorious you know they gave me
fifty thousand dollars
you know um i'm sipping champagne by the
pool
you know like the lobby is great has my
name all over it
you know like oh man i gotta get there i
got it i gotta get there yeah no like
it's just
being in game right now just it's just
an exclusive experience
you know i'm sorry to those of you who
are waiting on the outside but
you know but in all seriousness i've got
i've gotten in game
i've unlocked valkyrie
[Music]
i have gone to the firing range tested
out the bow
um they did something with the lighting
engine because the game looks
really a lot like a lot better and
uh i'm not just making that up but like
i bought the battle pass
i'm in game uh and
valkyrie has some really really good
lines shout out to
miss erica ishii doing the damn thing
she's such a vibe like both her and
valkyrie like
they're both are we talking about voice
lines yes yes
jordan is here let's go what up
yeah welcome jordan nice to meet you
nice to meet you as well are you ready
to carry me to victory
uh you know i did some stretches before
this my back is quite wide
you know i am good i am known to be
quite heavy you know
yeah all right so i'm restarting again
in hopes
that it's my turn amy said she had faith
that i'm gonna be next
i agree i have faith can i be the next
chosen one
please i see for anyone out there who's
still having trouble to get in
downloading the update
here's what i did if i you're on steam i
verified the game files
and restarted team steam two times
before
an update even showed up then once the
update showed up before downloading it i
verified game files again
exited steam entered back steam download
the update verified game files
again and then i was able to get in
i was able to get in game and i just got
disconnected like a little bit ago with
codenet but i made it immediately back
into the game
so it is very much possible for you to
get in right now
i very much think it has to do with like
file verification
because i've had issues with apex
patches before where not all the files
download properties to get like some
weird textures
but if you're having issues try that
i can i can i can show you the way to
the promised land of getting inside the
servers
i literally took off work for
did take over this so funny yeah but
you know it's great over here uh the
weather's fail the weather is fantastic
um i'm really nervous to click ready to
go rubbing it in now
all right you're just rubbing it too
much now i'm gonna go verify my let's
try
the nikail strats right here
let me go verify these files
once i learn where i can do that okay
i found it yeah all right so while
that's happening
i just read in the chat that reynaldi
said
i need an additional three gigs on
switch for this update that is an
interesting like point to bring up
because
my switch is already capped at space
even though i want to actually download
apex on my switch as well
but i'm also curious to know how arenas
is going to feel on switch
because like terrible i feel like the vr
part is already like a monument like
monumental challenge
but then arenas on top and i feel like
be even crazier on switch
like what do you use do you use like um
the pro like bait like controller or the
joy cons i want to see like a
professional
apex joy-con user
there is can't be done perfectly done i
tried playing with the joy-cons when i
was reviewing the game i'm like there's
no
conceivable way to play a first person
shooter with nintendo switch joycons
i guarantee you there's some kid out
there
who this is the only way he's learned
shooters and has no other reference
point
and is just are they or she or she or
they
and is beasting it up on down the
servers yeah
thanks i'm just stealth old and out of
touch man
still forward six six with the let the
trailer is a documentary
documentary that that's real that
happened all right
so i am verifying my files
it looks like it might be about halfway
through it's taking a while which tells
me maybe
it's doing something right
yeah like i've had issues where like the
like files don't download properly in
this you can't get into the server at
all
so yeah no i i
think this is the issue some people are
running into um because it happens to me
on season eight and season seven
and if you once in the 80s says
fool i'm the joycon player see
we got one right there
exactly wow we have the
pathfinder in the chat that's amazing
yo pathfinder hello friends
speaking of pathfinder the apex book
pathfinder's quest for those of you lore
heads
uh it seems like from some of the voice
lines that i'm seeing
in game that they've added stuff is
starting to get referenced
from it so
i'm not going to point out specifically
what in case people haven't seen it
but this is just like i think this is a
gentle nudge by the devs that hey
you haven't read it we're gonna start
referencing stuff from this go
read it it's really good
um white tigers so they they're gonna
buy the battle pass and unlock some new
legends
okay so besides valkyrie obviously which
other legends
are you looking to unlock because
there's legends plural i'm assuming
there's a few more you got your eye on
i'm pretty like interested in seeing
like
new players who are coming in which
other characters they kind of have their
eye on
files verified okay let's get in there
i'm just watching your efforts persia
trying my absolute best
yeah i'm building the bridge right now
we're going to make it over to you i'm
calling the people up to respawn saying
let persia in right now
i know calling all my favors all of them
you want all the legends honestly
that's fair and we were talking about um
pathfinder's quest hint hint nudge nudge
go read it
once you read that you'll definitely
want to play every
every legend pretty much huh so once you
read that everything you
like appreciate about apex legends just
changes
so fundamentally like you see every
character in a completely new light
i know it's so oh
i cried so much and then at the end
i don't want to spoil anything oh man
just bangalore's chapter alone i'm like
man i know i know this yep
miss anita williams herself
doing the thing it is i got my hardcover
it is quite it's a quite good book
it's a it's a quite good book um
a lot better than i was expecting tbqh
because
i remember the days of video game tie-in
novelizations
and
[Laughter]
those are the days when you go into
barnes noble and you find like a halo
book
oh my godness i remember reading a halo
book you can do it persia
you can do it i'm trying are you guys
able to party up with each other
and then maybe one day what's your name
in game uh
just you have to send it out just turn
it in the chat send to the chat
yeah only because i know your username
is
video like funny
hush purse
[Laughter]
would it behoove you to know that i have
the almost exact same
uh username and a bunch of other things
but instead it starts with dis
yes you know how many different
variations of that i had to
input before i finally got one
apparently there's just a lot of people
who want a variation of that user i
probably took some of them
to be cute to be quite honest i probably
took a good portion of them
it's your fault yeah i've been sitting
on a lot of those
names a lot of people are starting to
get through now people are still facing
issues but some people have been in for
a while some people are
just getting in do you buy valkyrie or
save your coins for something else
i guess it depends um sputlife what kind
of playstyle do you
like like what other legends do you like
to use because
i would say valkyrie is interesting in
a way that she can kind of meld like a
few different
play styles together
i feel like i am a very aggressive
player especially like you know i use
horizon i'm always like rushing in doing
crazy stuff
and i feel like valkyrie can still give
me that like
satisfaction of being able to fly
and like be in the air and like get high
ground easily but also
reign me in on not being so crazy when i
play
because she also doesn't really have the
capability to like
go and be like a one-person show i guess
although she's a recon character she's
not designed to
lead the attack yeah because i feel like
she's going to be a good middle ground
for
for players like me to not just run in
and die
i'm that meme where they're like just
cause you hear gunshots doesn't mean you
have to run over there i'm like
yes it does what do you mean like what
are you talking about
say i'm even worse persia because i i
use a few characters but i think my
most often returned to is probably
octane so
i'm like oh there's a fight over there
not only can i get there i can get there
while leaving my teammates behind this
is a perfect plan
and i can arrive at half health yeah
let's do
this all right jordan i sent you
an invite
you might have to accept it in games i
think it's through uh ea
yeah oh snap
mark got into the game i'm excited for
you guys honestly
i've been having this little spinny
thing here for a while
which is not a yes but it's also not a
no
like it was before yes something
definitely has changed
no so
we'll see thank you guys for your
patience
when will the server start you know
[Music]
uh i will let you know once i get in but
i feel
it started to some capacity because you
guys already in
yo shout out to my man mark buren chat
saying server amsterdam are online
i mean if you really really want to play
right now
you could change your data center to
amsterdam and play with 150 ping
we gotta get those midwest servers split
the difference
is that the legendary arrogant i hear
the legendary maybe
perhaps the update is a beefy one
that is true yes especially if you're in
console
i would definitely say block out some
time um
i've heard reports of anywhere from 50
to 70 gigs for some people
for console um the total for me on pc on
steam was only 10.
so but i know some people have different
numbers based on
something i honestly don't know why
but yeah no definitely if you're on
console block out some time
hook yourself directly up to the
ethernet cut
and make sure no one else in your house
has a zoom call or anything to do
uh yeah like
it's
we don't got time for this guys we don't
i
i need to play
[Laughter]
okay no
i'm just terrified to click the ready
trying to get button games in at least
for whatever
reason the notification of the
connection requests never came through
to me i'm checking my ea account
uh settings right now i'm like maybe
i've accidentally said it that it's like
block
everyone who isn't already on my
friend's list
i see all right i see you sent another
friend request
60 gigs on origin wow
that seemed like a ladder also pc uh
origin
does not on yeah
more switch players they're showing up
now they heard you
i told you there's a there's there is a
club
of god like switch players out there who
was just ready to prove all of us
wrong i was just sitting here like
in the background you know tapping my
fingertips together
yes the switch army is showing up now
that actually is a good question night
angela can awesome get an old accelerant
and get her old and also her tactical at
the same time
that is definitely something that would
be game changing in arena since you have
to pay
for abilities but if you pay for it
ultimate accelerant
as watson you get your full thing i'm
like trying to
i don't even think ultimate accelerants
are in arena are they
because you have to buy your own
i'm not sure i don't think that i mean i
don't i played it but i feel like
i didn't even think about the ultimate
accelerants when i was playing so i
didn't think to look for them but
i'm not sure that those are in there at
all
well they probably thought about this
before because i'm just thinking about
uh watson just buys five ultimate
accelerants i just always have a trophy
system
you know what i did see was that
because i had originally thought you
couldn't buy your old until like after
the third round because most of them
were like that but lifelines you could
buy lifelines
right off the start hmm
yes advertise to everyone where you are
[Laughter]
come on apex i believe in you
rename the stream to chat bonds if we're
not getting into
the servers yeah exactly like we're
bonding here you guys
you know shout out to everyone
watching a bunch of other apex streamers
be at this exact same screen
there's gotta be someone in that
streaming matches by now you think
uh well last time i checked all of
twitch is just people on the title
screen okay good i feel less bad then
because i'm like man
last time i checked shiv was still on
uh the main the main screen
yeah he is she was still in the origin
launcher um
lulu is still on the main screen
dr lupo still on the main screen
um nice wig
also still on the main screen and shout
out to you all those streamers by the
way
like yeah these are all my friends be
like watching
and like cracking up so much
at a lot of what these guys do on
youtube so
definitely check them out is this in the
mainstream but if this preview is right
and munition
is in game oh of course she would need
because she's the best
and munition is in game shout outs to
her erica
erica ishii the voice actress of
valkyrie herself
she is not she is not engaged
you need to get on that right now
uh dyrus says he's playing fx legends
but he's playing auto chess so
you know that's a mix-up in itself um
tanner's on main screen girls on the
main screen man i might be one of the
only people
[Laughter]
well we're just gonna give you guys the
feed of the kyle's dream while he plays
while
i try to get in yes if he one of the
writers of apex legends is still on the
main screen
i'm telling you i know it sucks i know
we're all like dang we can't get in but
think about it
so many people want to play apex right
now that we cannot get in
that is a beautiful plot yeah
that's uh so if it lets you feel any
better
the official voice actors of the
characters
and some of the actual devs of the game
cannot get into their own game right now
so you are not alone
please feel better um
let me see if i can do something here
yeah try to start a game i just want to
see if you can actually play i'm going
to see if i can
i'm going to see if i can stream to the
discord yeah
and i'll pull your feed on to the screen
and
we're trying
if it's the last thing we do okay let's
see
uh i don't know how the quality is gonna
be
all right you guys we're oh
okay hold up can i
pop this out i can technology
okay add i'm a professional guys don't
worry about this i can do this on the
fly
it's all yeah you're getting about to
get some exclusive
screen captured footage of apex
[Music]
i cannot vouch for how good the quality
is gonna be of it
yeah because it's like a stream of the
stream basically is what we're gonna
attempt to give you guys
so we will turn this on we'll drag this
over here
but i'm about to give you some exclusive
4k footage of me
pressing the ready button and praying
that i stay in game
i know um how do i do
oh here we go
but yeah if you are trying to get in
keep trying
you have the world trying with you
quite literally okay so
i have pulled up you obviously see we're
on this card here
this is mikhail's stream of his gameplay
here yeah try to get into a match let's
see if
uh let's see if we have any luck
we can watch you play for a bit while i
try to get in in the background
all right i am going to press the ready
button
do it do it
i'm not mad nervous sorry yeah
[Laughter]
i can try streaming the app but i don't
know how to do that
from the call
oh but you know it's fine
it's better than nothing which is what i
had before
there's four players in the queue right
now um
the four chosen ones i wonder if that
includes you
to be honest yeah uh
[Music]
i i i don't know what
i did to get chosen oh starting the
server
starting the server excite i mean
honestly
it's three on three you only need oh you
only need six people
to start this
all right
but is it coming through on the streams
all right
possibly i'm hoping so
jg says just play already guys yeah come
on guys
all of you just play already what's
what's wrong with you guys why aren't
you playing
why aren't you playing this i
am playing as hard as i can to click the
ready button i am anxious i'm sweating
i'm sorry i'm right now yeah now
i'm i'm i'm i'm cracked irl right now
you uh logged into
my kyle i'm logged on to the virginia
server
because i live in virginia and uh
yeah um
[Laughter]
i i just got baited by the chat
it's weird person just a second ago you
were showing us online
for apex legends and xbox and now it
shows you as offline were you
technically logged in on your xbox as
well
i mean i do
have xbox like on my pc like the game
pass thing but i don't
i'm not even launching oh so maybe it
was registering that
it still starts starting the server the
server is starting still
all right one step i hate your
many steps ahead of us right now so
i mean guys i got a load screen i got a
lot
okay wait we gotta make gun sound
effects
for him so you're about to have some
exclusive
4k captured footage of
it's one of the first arena games
being played right here on gamespot
this is awesome
[Music]
oh and like someone's already got the
amazing
amazing skin they wasted no time
they wasted no time whatsoever exciting
okay so we are capturing this footage
um i'm just scared you guys know this
i'm gonna try and i don't
i mean i'm gonna move my camera so that
we could see maximum screen
so yeah uh don't judge me too hard
let's see what this loadout is let's uh
okay i had an idea of a loadout that i
wanted to do um i
have double time already i have two
charges of smoke um
so what i'm gonna do first is go with a
p2020
and then i'm gonna go with a shield bat
and then bank the rest
[Laughter]
that free 20 20 i'm gonna bank the rest
i'm banking the rest i'm saving it bold
strategy
bold strategy cotton all right
so um you better drive shock and luck
we got to make the sound effects you
know
gotta make the flips i will try to
stream
the app directly okay cool
it's okay we got you on the sound
effects you know we got feet all right
they're up there
hit the feet
[Music]
double time in it what would you do for
like an
l star it's like a sound
[Laughter]
pew pew pew pew pew pew pew
the laser beam
knocks nice the team's closing in on the
enemy valk and they get the first round
let's go i told you i
banked the points
getting a bow check and
okay what else i'm getting a gold
backpack
i'm gonna get some grenades
and another shield bat
yeah all right see
we told it we i told you what was gonna
happen
yes see it's all calculated already
all right so are we going with the bow
yes because i have to show are you
playing in hdr right now
i am not an hdr my screen is hdr
yeah um it looks a little brave on our
side but like
not to change or anything it's for the
viewers it's probably because we're
he's streaming into discord and i'm
streaming off of the discord stream so
it might not
look like this when you play so
definitely don't think they're like whoa
they added the brightness to the game
it's just how we're setting it up right
now because
kyle's been the only one who's been able
to get in
oh big damage on the blue shield
and hit him snippety snipes with the bow
check
one goes down and kyle he is on the
offensive trying to close the gap but
they close the door
just in at times gonna go up the flank
but someone's behind
oh a centimeter away from the noggin
the octane getting schmoved on and the
teammate comes in with the help
they're fighting against the last one
there's smoke everywhere care package
just came down pathfinder takes down the
kyle but is getting chased
by the other two teammates can
pathfinder close it out
or will he get team shot how is he still
alive this madman all right here we go
round number two victory
all right match point everybody match
point on
game one because this is how we like
game spot alright
you know yeah even though you know
nicole's showing up for team b and b
right now respect put some respect on
team b and b's name
[Laughter]
all right back at it match points
i'm going with a a bow check and a
peacekeeper
a bow tech and a pk
oh the ground emotes bangalore v stylin
all right we all have purple shields as
you can see i know it's getting a little
choppy guys let's let discard ketchup
it's good i know they're like it's laggy
i know it i know it is
no no okay it looks like it's evening
out a little
all right got the oh got the boat check
drawn
valkyries sending missiles your way
moved forward to avoid
one drop down below we got some high
ground two up top
and kyle drops down to get a separate
angle looks like the team is trying to
set up for a care package
they actually made it up top let's see
if nikail can
make it up there in time
sniping with the peacekeeper you miss
those days guys i know you do
pk's back oh i'm so happy for it to be
back
i was an absolute menace in season three
with the peacekeeper
oh the teammate the saving grace
pathfinder again almost a repeat
from last round pathfinder once again
has the enemy team on his back and there
we go
champions of the arena
good job good job mikael
flex in with that ground emote
i love it now if apex would let me do
that
that would be great
[Laughter]
i'm so glad it's back pk for life heck
yeah
all right that was the one of the first
arena matches
of uh don't mind the fact that i missed
five pk shots in a row oops i just
dropped my controller
but i am still in so what i'm going to
do now is attempt
to do a different kind of stream see i
can get audio okay
um i am going to
attempt
this to share the application as you can
see you guys
i unfortunately have not
gotten in yet we're trying
we're trying
all right i'm gonna
i'm gonna have to all right give me
one second i think it's it doesn't like
the fact that it's in full screen
so what i'm gonna do is set to
borderless windowed
and then stream effects legends
and let me know if you all can see that
i'm going to attempt to restart this
again
all right so does she do people want me
to go
into firing range so i can show them
some stuff no
hit it hard in the arenas okay
that's what we really want to see here
i pulled up uh so it should be streaming
with audio now
um and uh let me know if it comes
through
for y'all
oh i hear audio endorses excite
i hear something
all right so i'm gonna attempt to get to
another arena's match
so you guys should be able to hear audio
now thank you
also nick for helping us so much here
yeah no worries i want you all to still
have some quality um
and don't judge me when i miss
peacekeepers
i am not used to having this thing in a
long time
i haven't used the peacekeepers
consistently in a while
but yeah no so i have some audio for
y'all um this is capturing at
at 4k but it's outputting at 1080p 60 so
um yeah no so hopefully
for anyone who has questions i will do
my best to answer them
um i can to let you know right now
valkyrie's q does 25 damage and does
it slow the same time as an arc star um
so the whole reason why i was able to
help follow up that on that pathfinder
there was because that
um and i am in the queue right now
for arenas the bow check does 70 damage
normally to the body
and then 126 to the head
um no that doesn't sound right i have to
go back into firing range
but it's a hundred and it's 130 120
something
but it feels really good to use
um that one shot though was crispy like
you should clip that everyone downloaded
shadow play i clip
everything now yes so i am
bringing y'all some more arena gameplay
it seems like the arena rotation
is every like 30 minutes
yeah shorter than the vr rotations for
sure
yeah which i think is kind of cool
actually because there's more maps and
stuff too
um so for those in chat real quick who
are saying how are we
in well i personally am not in
but our pal nick here did get in did
play a match
um so don't worry if you're thinking
it's only your setup it's definitely not
a lot of us still can't get in
there are a lot of streamers who make a
lot more money than me who can't stream
this game right now
so shout out to whoever respawn was
looking out for me
for real you know this this one boy in
virginia servers man yeah help him out
like i don't know if this is like
i don't know man i like the actual voice
actor for valkyrie can't get in the game
and i feel so bad
i know
am i getting in the am i oh
it was doing some stuff like it was
gonna let me in and then it said
no server found i got excited
and also if your game's not properly
working make sure you verify game files
because sometimes with the updates
not all the proper files install
properly that is something i've noticed
hmm let me
in so the server is starting yours again
the server is starting still oh
but it just switched maps because it's
taken so long to queue
so you guys saw uh the artillery map
but you are now we are now going to the
phase runner map
i really like face runner i think it's
my favorite of the two new maps
hmm my favorite might be party crashers
only because i like halfway know it
already because the boat is there
it's familiar yeah
yeah don't try and buy apex coins right
now um
don't don't spend any crafting materials
on anything
uh but
hopefully
yeah well alex got in congrats
let's go switch players rise up
but yeah my method for getting in was
verifying my game files like four or
five times
and as i'm one of the only people that's
in it seems like that's
the fix goodness all right i'll try it
you know it worked for you it costs me
oh perspective
i didn't know that valkyrie's legendary
skin where she's wearing
my first helmet was going to be in the
game at lunch
yeah yeah
so for whatever reason right now i
cannot check legends let out our store
but that happened when i was first
booting up and
um but i am still in the match ranking
queue
is it starting or did you restart it i
restarted it
because i think i think the map changed
so i think i'm gonna need to but yeah no
so
i would show you go through valkyrie's
stuff if i could
but i
but you know it's the big update
everyone loves titanfall they had a
titanfall free weekend
um and you know
it's uh it's something real special to
see
something real a few more people are
getting in though in the chat as well
so that might be good news for you so
your matches can start
uh i see springfield has the
actual answer they said guys i got into
an arena match all i had to do was keep
screaming let me in
let me end that sounds about right i'm
gonna keep trying that
let me end
dang see this is what happens when i get
really excited for stuff
usually that means like everyone else is
my equal amount of excitement so
we're all like yeah no i'm just
you know i took off work and i know a
lot of other people did so i really hope
everyone can make it in
because man the last time i took off of
work for a game
was literally master chief collection
and it was the last time because i
couldn't play it and i was like dang i
took off work and then i couldn't even
play it
yeah i master chief collection is funny
because i had me and my friend from
college
who now i think works over at twitter we
literally stayed up until midnight for
master chief collection launch
and we didn't know that there were any
matchmaking problems because we
literally just went into halo 3
legendary the last stage the warthog
good
and that was the very first thing we did
and there were tears in our eyes as we
were getting to hearing the nostalgia in
the college dorm room
back in what was this this would've been
like what 2014
2015 and
we both went to bed like man that was a
great experience wake up the next
morning people
mad my master chief collection were like
i don't what we were able to get in fine
so it seems like
there's just a comment could not get in
at all not only could i
not get in that day i couldn't get in
for like a month
it was like really messed up
like not a month straight but like i was
like okay i couldn't get in today
tried to get an x i couldn't get in then
i gave it like two days still couldn't
get in
and then like that over the course of
the month i was just still having
problems
until finally i was like oh snap i could
play
and then it was the best thing ever i
might be the only person in the
matchmaking queue
i am now there's actually might be no
one else in the match making
the chosen one like
so we're trying our best stream
we really are okay we have one or two
options
we can continue doing this but i have
some people are asking
for a firing range um
what are what are your thoughts about
that jordan and persian
i mean yeah sure it could hop in there
give
give the people what they want give them
some firing range
show them how different some of the guns
and
character abilities are
so i will be going into firing range uh
cue up your questions
so i can go and answer them um best i
can
give you that number crunching data that
you want
damage profiles see the numbers
yeah well there's 870 people queuing in
for firing range
well you know what we are dating
hold up my brain it took my brain a
moment to process what i had just heard
that's hilarious um
i was able to get in in firing range
earlier with valkyrie
so if things hold up i should be able to
get in again with valkyrie
um but we will see
at least we got one game
yeah we did get a game that i won
yeah we're not we're not liars we did
actually play one game of arenas
and valkyrie was in that game so
we hit every criteria from yes
and i am on the virginia server i do not
know
how if that's going to help as i am
located in virginia which is probably
why it's
working but uh that is why
i am able to connect because for
whatever reason virginia servers are
working right now
no your mileage may vary uh based on
where you are in virginia
because i'm located northern virginia um
but i know internet
coverage around the state can be a
little bit spotty
let me in
but i can let you know now the bow check
feels really good to use
uh i do not know how
it does not have as big of a range as
you think it does i will say that
yeah like it is not going to replace
snipers at all
and it is i can say you
it's quiet but you can hear it i mean
obviously if you're using headphones
probably but if you
have uh speakers
maybe depending on what your speaker
settings are
but um yeah it's the bow check feels
really good to use
there's 14 45 players in q for firing
range
everyone's like well if arenas isn't
working right now into firing range
legislatively more people are getting in
so if i go to arenas
yeah i have faith we can at least get
one more game in
because soon i mean as much as i'm sure
chat has enjoyed us sitting here doing
nothing the entire time
unfortunately we will have to conclude
stream here shortly if we are not able
to play
but that doesn't mean you guys should
not play
obviously the update just dropped
you know within the last few hours a lot
of people are playing
this is all a good signs of life for the
game
so regardless i'm excited
even if i can't play you know right this
second i know i will be able to play
eventually
you know the impatience in me is like
led me in though
everyone's getting in you guys now i'm
like kitty
i'm reading the chat and i'm like the
fomo is setting in now
i was trying to be you know you know
like patient and like you know
adult-like
and then i just saw everyone say i'm in
and i'm like
no good for you
so happy for you guys
[Laughter]
are you are you still in jordan
uh yeah i'm just messing with the
i haven't tried you should try and then
maybe we could pull your feet in here
too or you guys weren't able to add each
other huh
no no welp
oh my god and it's really good loot oh
everyone's freaking
the it's the volt with energy ammo and a
digital threat
i am restarting my game hopefully
i verified my files twice i might have
to go for that third time
third time might be the charm
actually this this might be a dumb
question but when you were searching for
my username were you
searching for me on pc or searching for
me on xbox because i realized that on
both pc and xbox my
username is exactly the same so you
might have
sent a notification to my
steam account instead of my well i
clicked fine
i clicked find friend and
let me it says you're a friend
friend but but i don't see you in my
list at all
like it says you have 100 been added
yeah i'm getting the same thing where
it's like this person's
a friend but then i go to the list and
it's like but
you're not there you know
sometimes it it do be like that
but i'm glad i was able to showcase at
least one game
and
[Laughter]
is nice wig yelling let me in so
he's using the method that was suggested
previously in chat
um he is shaking his chair uh so
definitely i feel like if he's able to
make it in that will
be proof that that method works um
so you know
if you have any incense you want to burn
if you have any gods
any gods to pray to you know
father that that would be the time now
sacrifices maybe
um that would be that would be a thing
um some people are saying the
matchmaking servers are down so let me
try this firing range
um because i would like to get in there
and show you guys what i was able to see
because i was able to i played around
with valkyrie some movement stuff and
her ability to get velocity is quite
interesting
um like being able to sprint carry that
momentum forward with the jet pack
but like it's there's a lot more there
than i thought
tournament servers
yes so also one of the cameras update
they are having tournament servers on
xbox
which means that for algs and stuff in
the future
uh people on console
will be able to i heard the noise
all right so all right and i'm back in
the game
it's valkyrie time so here you go i was
able to get in
and show everyone some valkyrie so
first off the bat does anyone have any
specific things they want to see
uh i'm gonna use the bow
guys all right so
bow 70 to the body
123 to head so i wasn't that off
um abilities
i oh and i got changed to wraith
time to drop shock and rock
i was volker it's
so it is now saying it valkyrie is
locked even though i selected her
hacks cannot see
the forbidden texts
so but i could i can still show off
some of the hop-up stuff and weapons
so all right so
shatter caps all right let me get out of
the deck
so shatter caps 77
in and if i get all to the head
okay so if i get all the shatter caps
that i had
98. all the shadow caps to the
all the shader cats to the bodies 77.
so definitely something that's not as
bad as a peacekeeper but you still have
to respect it
like this is gonna be able to mess
someone up
but the thing is about shadow caps at
range
it's like from here you're getting 66.
so if i back up here
like just if i get just on the dummy
it's like 66 from like i would say
this this place here like you switch
like uh
like auto to single fire yes so
you if you have if you have the shadow
caps on you switch from there
and then here you have some tempo thing
so if i hit this target over and over
again
i can just keep doing that but the
minute i take any time
to stop like
that's up for
arrows
all right so i'm keeping up this
momentum as you can see it's a little
bit
lenient but the minute i like take any
second to zoom in
it's gone so
if you zoom in and want to use
marksmanship i'll get this days again
so it's pretty much like you want to
make sure you hit your marksman tempo
while you're zoomed in um
okay what else changed so
triple take care back at triple take
so i forget what the numbers were before
but
the numbers now i think they changed
something
138 to the head 69 to the body
so if you have purple shield that's
going to hurt a lot
peacekeeper
it's definitely not as powerful as it
was before
and it's definitely
still you still have to respect it
in this range but
it's not like gonna map you like it did
in season one
and stuff because
because like a challenge
i'm i'm hitting like almost every single
pellet to the head here
and it's like 84. not like the 100 and
something that it was before yeah the
110 that you would get
oh wait i'm closer
i have to like if i am right here
inside there 121. but
if i am right here inside your face at a
hot at like 121.
you deserve to die like okay so
non-choke
is also 121 because my cursor is their
whole head
like so at that point if you're if
you're choking it
this close there's no purpose to doing
that
but if i'm like back if i'm like back
here
trying to hit them in the head like
perfectly lined up in the crosshairs
you're getting like 73 80 something
because of the pellets
for a shotgun though it's 84.
he's like i'm trying to get like the
absolute highest i can get from distance
like you still have the two pellets at
the bottom they're still in that star
pattern they're gonna miss
so from like let's go this way he's here
because he's flat by that thing
18 20 let's say 20 meters out right
82. in terms of being able to cover the
mid-range the peacekeeper is still quite
good
um but it's not gonna like immediately
kill you like it did before but you
still have to respect it
um okay what else changed oh spitfire
the spitfire
recoil so they said they changed the
recoil at the beginning of the spitfire
so i'm gonna aim here let's relocate him
and i'm 35 meters out
i haven't no this is
this is no stock this is completely
stock uh spitfire
so i'm a little bit concerned because
okay i'm aiming for the center of this
[Music]
all right so i'm gonna see if i can get
a bullet
like image here of what it looks like
that is the spitfire's recoil pattern
it's just a c
it's it's it's just a c so this is me
actively trying to like
actively trying to like control it
wow really not that hard so this
this spitfire okay spitfire hip fire
that's a pretty accurate i would say
okay guys i've also made a great mistake
i was like let me just restart
steam maybe that'll help and now i can't
even get into steam for some reason
so all right let me try to get on
let's reposition here i'm gonna do
hip fire spitfire out from 10 meters
that's the bullet spread of it from like
10 meters
so then aim down sights at 10 meters
with that level of control what's even
the point of using the flat line
yeah exactly like it's still
that general c pattern as you see some
deviation at the beginning
but like it's still a c so if you just
hold down and left
then you're you're good the flat line
which is my baby i don't know
because the flat line like if i get
a fang of the flatline
and then hip fire
they're still generally on center but
so moral story the spitfire is
still gonna be a problem um
yeah i wish i had something nice to say
about that but you know
all right so let's see pete the 30 30
shatter caps
so the boat shutter caps the 30 30
center cap so the 30 30 shatter caps
say we are from 10 meters like before
48 but
that is gonna get someone down very
quickly
i don't know how you're so good with
that gun man
because the hip fire on it is extremely
like
reliable like i can be from out here
i know i'm not gonna hit that dude
all right
[Applause]
you can hit fire it and uh
[Applause]
and then shatter caps from this distance
[Music]
do shatter caps get charged they do get
charged
yeah shatter caps on 30 30 are quite
good
and they've actually made the 37 viable
i could not use that gun throughout all
of season 8.
so like absolute best case scenario you
can three tap someone if you're hitting
like three or four
so again something like an eva eight if
i test
that this is now just evolved into
science time since i can
fake valkyrie so you know
yeah i was seeing in the chat that
people weren't able to use any of the
new champions
at all so must be a overall thing right
now
at the moment yeah um i still
unfortunately cannot get in
so after me go ahead and wrap up the
stream unfortunately
but maybe later this week we can do
another stream where we
actually get to play together and
everything is working again
so yep and just for
one more for the road yes
of course
show those dummies huge boss
i feel like this is karma's because we
got to play the play test and now
they're like you already tried it all
right
you guys let other people enjoy it and
you know what
it's it's true you guys should enjoy it
i'm looking forward to it
i hope everyone gets in eventually we'll
see you guys next time and thank you so
much for being here
peace out